Our columns work pretty well, but
if we start putting text in them, you can see that things get pretty cluttered.
It can be really difficult to read when the words are so
close to each other in adjacent columns.
In design, we have a concept called negative space.
That is to say, space that doesn't contain anything.
On the Udacity website, we can see pretty easy examples of negative space.
Between this text here in this paragraph and this icon,
we have this empty space that makes it easy for this text to stand out.
It makes it much more readable, the page feels less cluttered, and our brains
don't have to work as hard to figure out what this page is trying to tell us.
To make this paragraph more legible, let's go into Dev Tools and
add some padding.
I will right click, go to inspect element, and we can see that
we're selecting this paragraph, this p tag which corresponds to this text.
And, to make changes just to this piece of text,
I'm going to go to element.style.
So this is only going to affect this paragraph, I can click in here and
start typing.
So let's add the CSS class padding and we'll do ten pixels,
that sounds pretty good, and I'll close this.
Notice that the red box around the paragraph didn't change, but
there's some extra space here, already making it much easier to read.
Padding is a great strategy to create some negative space between elements.
But, what if instead of creating space inside the element,
we wanted to create space outside the element.
To do that, we'll use margins.
First off, I refresh the page.
Then I'm going to right click here, and go to Inspect Element.
So, once again, we're looking at the same paragraph, but
things are back to normal.
Let's make a change.
Now, this time we want to push it away from other elements, so
we'll use a margin instead.
Margin 10 pixels, why not?
Press Enter and close Depth tools, and
now notice how there's a red box around the paragraph that has some
extra space on the outside between it, and the column four.
This is called a margin, padding was on the inside, margins are on the outside.
This is another great way to create some negative space between elements.
If you're ever confused about what's creating the space around an element,
you can actually look it up in Dev Tools.
If you scroll down to the bottom of this CSS lists, we can see the box model for
the entire page here.
We've got a margin of eight pixels, which we can see highlighted.
Then we have a border of 0.8 pixels.
And then inside the border,
we have, well, no padding, because we don't see any numbers here.
And, then we can see the size of the screen.
Using the box model is a great way to figure out how elements are being laid out
on the page.
If this black box were an element on the page, we've got options for
spacing it out against other elements.
Margins let us push elements away from each other,
while paddings create space internally.
In the example we just looked at, we just used the generic margin and
padding to affect all four sides of the element, but we can also add a side to
get a little bit more specific, using either top, bottom, left, or right.